have a 70 year old woman dress you for
the rest of your life roasting up or
English fry up and obviously if you had
a superpower what would it be and the
blades are moving yeah the house is on
fire what do you grab although you've
got a parry trap you
I feel look yeah I still feel that too
still as smart I mean it's what it's
matches and it's still like it's
something it's just okay it won't suit
anyway sweet or savory savory chips or
burger burger double cheese bacon
backing chips and McDonald's and now I'm
on the chips Wow yeah world first
exclusive you've got to busk
on the streets of Liverpool mm-hmm all
cupboards look your own lovely what what
free songs do you choose
Oh Days nights she loves you never
perform live or never enter studio again
[Music]
I'm gonna have to say yeah never the
shoe job really live I actually used to
hate the studio what I just thought I'd
love to someone my head do I have any
idea I want to be in and out in two
three hours yeah where's live Michael
I'm with ya cool oh never listen to The
Beatles again only listen to The Beatles
forever rest of times anything you can
tell me licious reveals Claire that you
accidentally come into possession of one
of John Lennon's guitars I don't got to
be an accident
yeah just a national call goes out
return punishment I guess I'll just take
dressing like me like boxing I love
boxing my favorite sport yeah what for
would you ever wear I thought about that
I bought I always get the time don't
mean the band would wear them for
something but we never got rounds but I
actually bought five this is one artists
that are alive can feature
[Applause]
who's the most famous person in your
phone it would be yeah yeah who would
you most like to have a three-day bender
with dead or alive while I'm in it yes
t-rex yes they're in the car love it so
you're in prison you're on death row
right and you you're on your way to the
electric chair I'm embellishing this
question what's your last meal gotta be
fried chicken or hot wings
what buffalo sauce yeah super hot blue
cheese did love it I didn't like the
bits everybody friend loved that Oasis
or blur Oasis wish favorite Oasis anyone
hey now on what's the story Morning
Glory
good show yesterday Lennon or McCartney
it's a real tough one the older I get
the more
I was always big insulin I've always
classic and when you in a super band
with other people who okay and this is
the final question from the miles came
in amazing what would you prefer to step
in dog [ __ ] or get on your hands I think
they know you like shoes would you
rather get [ __ ] on you Gucci loafers or
[ __ ] on your hands and yeah
[Laughter]